hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast improved decision-making and
drug discovery process of using an
innovative approach to modeling chronic
liver disease
I'm Robert Castellanos of lab roots and
I'll be a moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth laberd's is a leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars contributing to the
advancement of science through content
sharing capabilities lab routes is a
powerful advocate and amplifying global
networks and communities they have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge a slide window by
clicking on the screen icon at the lower
right-hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or submit your
problem there's a green - in a button
lower left I would like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Steve England
Steve's is an experienced professional
in the early stages of drug discovery
and development from target
identification through project
initiation up to proof-of-concept steve
has a broad-based
scientific experience prior reality in
the neuroscience area and more recently
in chronic liver disease - more
generally immunology in oncology
currently Steve has two major roles
firstly leading the discovery effort on
the other disease at Alvie aimed at
identifying treatment for nash at nasa
LD and autoimmune diseases of the liver
secondly Steve heads the future of
therapeutics and technologies a team
tasked with the identification and
interrelation of a typical therapeutic
modalities and I'll turn it over to dr.
England for his presentation many thanks
Robert
thanks the introduction and before
start I would like to thank the rad lab
rooms frog for the opportunity to
present by this webinar as my title
suggests I actually have dual
responsibilities at add V I had future
therapeutics and technologies which is a
small group tasked with identifying a
typical and potentially disruptive
therapeutic modalities and typically
we're interested in things such as sale
or or gene therapies and as part of my
role we're also on the lookout for
technologies and approaches that more
generally add to our drug discovery and
development capabilities so the second
part of my role is that I had our
discovery group involved in the search
for therapeutics for chronic liver
disease and my presentation today
combines aspects of both of these
responsibilities I'll talk to you about
a new technology and how we apply it to
chronic liver disease discovery so
here's the breakdown of my presentation
firstly I'm going to start by providing
a very personal perspective on some of
the factors within discovery that I
believe contributes to later stage
attrition I'm going to touch on aspects
of systems biology and how I believe the
approach and the adoption in the
principles of systems biology may
address some of the contributors to
attrition I would suggest that the
invivo model probably represents the
ultimate systems biology approach at
least within discovery and I'm going to
talk to you about some of the challenges
associated with some of the preclinical
models in my particular area of interest
which is chronic liver disease I'm going
to present our approach which actually
uses what I believe to be a novel
technology and it focuses on a
particular aspect of liver pathology
I'll really go into some detail about
how we believe it reduces time costs
animal use and maybe more importantly
enables us to make better decisions more
rapidly with regards to our programs so
before I start I'm real
going to put out some thought-provoking
observations I believe we need to
continually re-evaluate how we approach
research and development within the
pharma industry and I think it's fair to
say we have to look ourselves in the
mirror and have to agree that across the
industry we probably haven't been as
productive as we need to be so so why is
this well I just bullet-pointed here
some of the reasons that I believe could
be contributing factors again a very
personal perspective and these are meant
to provoke thought but I think as
technology advances we're increasingly
aware that disease biology is extremely
complex and we know if we aim at a
single novel target very often they
don't translate into clinical success I
also think it's fair to say that there
might be one or two exceptions to this
but I think out of infectious disease
there are actually few drugs that alter
the underlying cause of disease most of
the treatments that we currently have a
symptomatic in nature and I still think
there's a large amount of potential
target space that we regard as
undruggable and by that I mean we view
them as undruggable because we think
small molecule and large molecule
approaches and I think this is likely to
change in the future so although we have
an increase in the knowledge of the
basic science I actually think that
isn't really translating through to
innovation in how we do our drug
discovery and how we do development we
know the cost of drug discovery and
development is increasing and you know
maybe the checkpoint inhibitors might be
the exception to this but I think there
are very few new game-changing
therapeutic modalities and I think very
interestingly medicine isn't different
from that practice decades maybe even
hundreds of years ago it relies on an
individual becoming ill and then going
to their physician who would prescribe
some kind of medication but I think as
we understand more about the genome the
whole
emphasis of how we treat disease is
going to shift to prevention rather than
cure and I think that is something that
Big Pharma really will have to get to
grips with in a not too distant future
and having said that I still think Big
Pharma's approaches to drug discovery
has been largely unchanged over the
years so this is the usual schematic of
drug discovery I do not like this
approach because it makes a number of
assumptions firstly it assumes that we
have a fixed rate of attrition such that
in the discovery phase we tend to see
the duration of getting in a preclinical
acid into the clinic of somewhere
between six to eight years it suggests
also I think that we are locked in to
research and development timelines if we
were to map on top of this continuum
there would be a large inflection point
when an asset crosses from the
preclinical phase into the clinical
domain and I think what that means is
for us very often we think that the
greatest economies can be bought within
clinical development I actually think
that making better decisions within
discovery will help reduce our attrition
rates and I think anything that that
moves away from the shots on goal
philosophy such that all we need to do
is increase the number of assets to the
left hand of this continuum that's all
we need to do to increase our success in
terms of marketed products I think this
is really something we need to challenge
most vociferous Lee so I think one of
the most eloquent commentators on this
subject is Bernhard munis and here a
couple of snapshots from this was a
commentary piece that came out last
December I would encourage anyone
involved in farm R&D to seek out and
read read his work
but simply this says that the industry
has been victim to a perfect storm of
circumstances the molecular biology
revolution enables to identify to clone
to express potential targets of choice
and it became extremely easy to make
cell lines and run things like high
throughput screens and to trigger drug
discovery programs it was very easy to
be reductionist this was coupled to
enhancements in medicinal chemistry for
example combinatorial chemistry so
overall what this meant was that pharma
companies could generate huge compound
libraries running into the many millions
coupled with consultancy firms telling
us all that really what it was all about
with shots on goal and we just needed to
increase our productivity at the
discovery side of the business and we
would have increased success within the
clinic I think this is actually very
wrong and I think we need to challenge
this very firmly so how do we think
about this well maybe as a backlash to
the reductionist approach emerged the I
think increasing understanding that
they're actually moving away from the
reductionist approach and more into a
systems biology arena would provide more
success and this if you like spawned the
systems biology motion and this really
speaks to the the importance in having a
greater understanding of the interaction
of players within a biological system
and this was championed by Leroy hood
and I would argue that one of the
reasons for attrition was that we've
been too keen to follow the bystander
players as shown here if we consider
these are molecular pathways and I think
we've been too keen to look at the
bystander players in this as shown by
the red arrow and I think we've been
less interested or less able to find
that what we regard here is chokepoints
in the system to enable us to have a
better chance of getting a bigger bang
for our buck when we go into the clinic
so I believe systems biology is
important and I think you can derive a
different way of thinking and this is
really summarized on the right hand side
and what this actually means is is that
there's technology advances we generate
massive data sets and this will enable
us to be much better at understanding
very complex biology this in turn will
generate new questions to which we need
to go and find answers and so this is
really how our understanding is likely
to advance in the future it will move
hand-in-hand with technological advances
so so ok this might seem all well and
good but how do we actually apply these
principles to aspects of the drug
discovery program so here you can see
the traditional preclinical drug
discovery continuum right from the left
hand side we identified targets we
generate screen we identify hits we
exemplify those hitchens in the
discipline chemistry and eventually we
move these into in vivo models it's the
right place to have you indeed are
models on the right-hand side of this
but I think we can be much better in
applying the principles of systems
biology to in vivo modeling and also
keeping to the tenets of three arts and
I think this is really important we need
to avoid using animals as screening
tools and if we can make more effective
decisions earlier on reduce the number
of animal usage and reduce the number of
model studies that we are using then
that has to be good for the 3 R's so I'm
now going to change tack somewhat to
tell you a little bit about my area of
interest and this is chronic liver
disease so chronic liver disease was a
huge public health problem greater than
1/3 in u.s. citizens will have some
degree of chronic liver disease and
thankfully for most this will be mostly
benign fatty liver disease or steatosis
however for some individuals the
condition is severe it can lead to
inflammation a central point here and
once inflammation is triggered in the
liver
it can cause increasing levels of
fibrosis ultimately leading to cirrhosis
now I think most of us will be more
familiar with alcohol induced cirrhosis
and that's reckoned to be a fairly
severe disease but this is a much more
severe healthcare time bomb as this
non-alcoholic steatohepatitis is driven
primarily by poor diet obesity and
diabetes so as the incidence of diabetes
increases in the u.s. population we
would expect to see more patients
suffering from chronic liver disease so
as liver disease progresses there are
increased levels of fat laid down in the
liver and under normal circumstances the
liver is actually designed to handle
lipids but if the amount of lipid
overwhelms the ability of delivered-to
to deal with it it can trigger
inflammation shown in the central
portion of this cartoon this leads to
Nash non-alcoholic steatohepatitis and
this in turn begins the process of the
liver laying down increasing amounts of
collagen and other structural proteins
that make up the extracellular matrix
once the liver becomes more fibrotic
this is much more serious it can result
in the loss of metabolic function the
liver loses compliance and by that we
mean it loses its pungent texture and
becomes much more stiff maybe more
importantly are the cardiovascular
consequences of an increasingly fibrotic
liver these are extremely severe they
lead to
portal hypertension esophageal varices
that can bleed and soft encephalopathy
and eventually death unless the patient
receives a transplant so this is a very
big deal and many pharma companies are
engaged in the search for effective
treatments for aspects of chronic liver
disease now AB G's is no different in
this we have an interest in this area
but I'd like to say a little bit about
how we're approaching this because I
think it's a little different from from
the norm the field is moving extremely
fast and we have to be competitive
within this space so we have a time
bound engagement and by this I mean we
do not have an open-ended commitment
from our senior leadership here we know
we have to enter the area succeed in the
area in a very short order but really to
succeed in this in in this mode of
working we have to think differently and
we certainly have to adopt a very
different operating model to the
traditional farmer way of working a
traditional farmer way of working would
be to go out too high the relevant
experts to initiate target
identification to make cell lines and
initiate high throughput screens and all
of this constituent constitutes a very
long time lag and of course none of that
ensures success so so we've got a
slightly different way of approaching
this now this also creates a problem
when it comes to preclinical models of
liver fibrosis because these are chronic
pains very bit variably on the on the
stimulus but usually these run about six
weeks and so if we consider that the
chronic nature of the in vivo models
there is also a certain degree of
fuzziness associated with the endpoints
because these are very usually histology
and so over it overall the in life
component and the post study analysis
is extremely labor-intensive and very
time-consuming so what do I mean by
time-consuming this is a screenshot from
a review that highlights some of the
preclinical models of fibrosis things to
take note here are the durations for
fibrosis induction in these models and
as you can see that there at the time is
variable but the time needed for
pathology to develop is dependent upon
the skin the stimulus but is usually
pretty long not included on this slide
are some models of liver fibrosis due to
diabetes and and and diet induced liver
damage and those models can actually
last upwards of 6 months to enable the
fibrosis to develop in the livers so if
you consider running these chronic
models with compounds of interest isn't
really in keeping with our desire to be
very agile and flexible so what we did
was decided to adopt a slightly
different approach and focus on the
inflammatory component of liver fibrosis
and that's relevant because as I
mentioned before but it is the driver of
fibrosis somewhat independent of the
model that we use so we actually set
about modeling the inflammatory
component of liver disease using conquer
novel and I so a couple of things that
are really important to point out here
we're no longer focusing on the anti
fibrotic mechanisms just the upstream
driver so this is only relevant for
agents that are inhibitory to some of
the inflammatory processes we actually
think this is justified provided we use
compounds which we think work by this
component of the pathology now to do
this we use con con Agra and con a is a
plant leptin it has been widely used to
induce hepatitis in mice and also
explore some of the past physiological
inflammatory mechanisms downstream of
chronic now this has a relevance because
many of the pathogenic drivers in human
immune mediated hepatitis so by that we
can mean autoimmune hepatitis certainly
viral hepatitis maybe even some drug
toxicities seem to use common immune
pathways and inflammatory media so we
believe this is valid so
cannae produces a biphasic effect in the
liver I'm going to talk about this a
little more in a moment
we have a direct cytotoxic effect on
hepatocyte and this also causes a
significant infiltration of t-cells and
the release of large amounts of
inflammatory mediators and again the
importance of this is that inflammation
is the driver for lying down at the
extracellular matrix in the liver and
the initiation of the fibrosis
it's also worth pointing out that the
single injection of con a at least in
the mouse actually produces a very acute
inflammation in the liver and pretty
much the inflammation in the liver is
finished after a single injection after
about 24 hours after which the liver
returns it's a pretty normal function so
this is one of our insulin experiments
it's pretty much shows histologically
what I'm speaking to so on the left hand
side we see a histological section of
liver from a mouse treaties with vehicle
and here the red and the black have been
used to stain inflammatory cells in the
liver the middle panel Pike and Connie
shows a mouse who has received a single
injection of con ay and you can see
there's a high density of both red and
black stain cells in the canal liver and
on the right hand side this is a
separate experiment again a histological
sample from a liver from a mouse that
had received con a but
in this case prior to kanay this mouse
had received dexamethasone dexamethasone
is asteroid which suppresses
inflammation and as you can see the
right-hand panel shows a significant
decrease in the levels of red and black
stain cells which again is consistent
with the anti-inflammatory properties of
dexamethasone so it's important to show
a little more detail the mechanism of
action of con Canaveral and I and this
cartoon shows the mechanism in a little
more detail kana actually binds to a
man''ôs receptor on the sinusoidal
endothelial cells labeled sec here and
this is in the liver and what this
causes an acute breakdown in the tissue
architecture now what this does is
exposes the cut for cells KC in this
diagram which are the resident
macrophages in the liver secondary to
this part of this biphasic effect is a
t-cell infiltration and this T cell
infiltration really underpins acute
inflammatory response that we see Tucano
as the immune system really kicks fully
into gear we actually see a whole range
of cytokines and chemokines released
both into the systemic circulation and
also in the liver itself and the
right-hand panel here shows in the top
part a shows a systemic release of a
whole range of pro-inflammatory
mediators and underneath we can see the
liver levels of the same inflammatory
mediators and so this is illustrates a
couple of things firstly illustrates the
acute nature of the challenge because if
you as if you look at the 24-hour time
point here pretty much the cytokine
immune modulator release is pretty much
over and done with both in the
circulation and also in the liver
so we actually think this has the
clinical relevance and so we we think it
has a clinical relevance again because
many of the processes that we stimulate
using the qaule model are also seen in
human diseases such as autoimmune
hepatitis primary primary biliary
cirrhosis and primary sclerosing
cholangitis and in actual fact we can
also add to this the inflammation caused
by metabolic drivers the obesity and
diabetes induced inflammation in the
liver so we think that there is a real
relevant to con a in modeling
inflammatory drivers in chronic liver
disease in man
so to summarize our thinking where we
are up to now so we know we can evoke an
acute inflammation in the livers of mice
using con carnival and i we know that we
can focus on the inflammatory drivers of
liver fibrosis
by doing this it may enable us to triage
compounds of interest more rapidly and
it doesn't mean that we are replacing
more chronic models it means we have an
ability to triage compounds through the
carne model early and so this means that
we can go into more chronic models with
a fewer number of compounds each of
which will have a high confidence and
probability of success having said that
even if we assume the khanna is the
model and move to this more acute model
it still involves a histological
evaluation of the liver or biochemical
analysis of the liver after the study is
being done also it's quite involved if
you want to look at inflammatory
mediators in the circulation so what
this meant was we actually came to think
that maybe there might be a better way
of
now what we know is in humans when we
evoke large amounts of systemic release
of pro-inflammatory mediators it
produces what is known as a cytokine
storm
so this cytokine storm produces a fever
and a general lethargy and fatigue in
patients so we hypothesized that there
might be an analogous behavior that we
might be able to measure in in mice and
so collectively this thinking took us
towards the divine digital vivarium
technology which I'm going to talk about
in a moment because we believe that
maybe we could identify behavioral
endpoint against which we could test
compounds of interest so what I need to
do is provide you with some background
to the technology and it should be
important to point out that this stage I
actually have no financial linkage to
the company whatsoever it's just an
excellent technology and we've applied
it I think in a very novel way so volume
has their digital bivariate and what
this offers is the ability to
continually monitor Mouse behavior now
this is done in a remote fashion and
with minimal human intervention now the
way this works is that the individual
cages are wired with all sorts of
sensors to monitor both environmental
conditions and also a multi-parameter
except assessment of mouse behavior so
what this actually means is that you can
assess in real-time the activity of the
mice within the cages and this is done
because there are cameras within the
cages and this means that the mice are
monitored 24 hours a day continuing so
this is a fantastic technology but maybe
more importantly
the technology is sensitive enough to
measure respiration rate in mice the
technology does this by detecting the
movement of the mouse chest area during
periods when the mice is stationary and
I think this is really important because
this is one of the significant
advantages that the technology offers
because there is continual assessment of
animal behavior I think in a way that
would be impossible by a human
experimentalist and it would be
interesting to meet anyone who could
eyeball the mouse respiration rate over
a period of 24 hours and this is
something that the volume technology
offers us so when you run these
experiments what do you see so here we
have on the top panel measurements of
activity and a mouse relative to sake'
daeun rhythm so this is a single Mouse
in one of those activity cages the grade
our area shows the dark cycle so there's
a 12 hour dark cycle and the white
intervening bars show the light cycle
now what we actually have here on the
left-hand panel of the upper data here
you can see that on night 1 as the dark
cycle starts the animal becomes very
active and over the course of the
24-hour period the animal is active but
it gradually tails off over that 12 hour
period and as you can see in the light
cycle there is almost no activity of the
mouse and this is maybe not surprising
because the mouse sleeps during the day
so what we actually can see is on night
-1 this is the mouse doing is natural
singing the cage at night 0 khon kaen
RNA has been applied midway through the
dark cycle at the black arrow here
and it's clear here there's quite a
rapid decrease in the amount of activity
in the mouth as we might imagine the
following light cycle the mouse is
pretty quiescent but what we can see on
the second night is that there is a
significant suppression in the activity
of the mouse in response to con a the
bottom panel here shows this is collated
data from groups of six mice and a dose
response curve to concur novel innate so
there are a number of things that we can
take from this data it's interesting
that with zero con a so this is this is
a non inflamed liver there was less
activity on night 3 relative to the
activity that was seen on night one
so night one being the white bar night
three being the black bar and I suspect
what this reflects is less exploratory
behavior in a mouse that was a control
and this reduction in expiratory
activity probably reflects the animal
becoming more comfortable in the cage
and probably requiring less exploratory
behavior so we can see this in the
controls 15 milligrams per kilogram con
I actually didn't you vote any change in
behavior
neither did 20 make per kick con a but
as you can see at the top dose here 25
milligram per kilogram con a there was a
significant reduction in the activity of
the mouse on the night after injection
so really what we have here is this is
actually in keeping with our original
hypothesis and belief that circulating
cytokines would produce a state of
relative inactivity in the mice and this
could be analogous to the lethargy
fatigue that is seen in humans in
response to high levels of circulating
inflammatory mediators so this was
incredibly encouraging for us so the
next slide shows that in actual fact
Connie was actually having the effect
that we thought it was half so this is
not behavior this is measurement of
circulating liver enzymes alt and ast
are enzymes that are actually used in
clinical practice to assess the state of
liver health and if you look at the data
in both the left and right panels it's
clear that the top two doses of con can
a blonde a produced significant
elevations of circulating liver enzymes
and this is again consistent with our
hypothesis the 25 Nick per kick dose
produced a substantial increase in both
alt and ast and this is consistent with
what we know to be happening the
inflammation that is occurring within
the liver now there is an interesting
aspect to this and although the 20 mega
kick dose of con a actually caused an
increase in ast and alt levels if you
recall from the previous slide only the
25 per kick dose suppressed activity so
there seems to be some separation here
and one potential interpretation of this
is that the higher dose probably invoked
a greater degree of media to release and
that was what was necessary to actually
invoke the change in behavior within the
mice despite the fact that there were
still some ongoing information in the
liver so the next slide shows where the
volume technology really provides a
significant advantage over more
conventional approaches so here we can
see the change in respiration rate in a
number of mice in response to increasing
doses of Khon Kaen avila Nate now
clearly there is some overlap in the
data here but in general you can see
that there is a dose-dependent increase
in the respiratory right in response to
the kono challenge now really if you
think about this the the volume
technology here is measuring respiration
rate by monitoring the movement of the
chest wall of the mouth when it's
actually static over a fixed period of
time if you actually stop and think
about that that is a pretty phenomenal
ability of the technology to pick up as
this kind of change now it's still very
early days but but we actually believe
that the we can actually use this to
screen compounds that might that might
suppress inflammation in the liver such
that we can use this rather than have
post life analysis to determine what
compounds we want to advancement in the
more the more chronic models so this is
how we see the approach we can rapidly
assess compounds using the behavioral
endpoints we can actually see in real
time whether our compounds are having
any effects we think the study execution
is is going to be pretty rapid we can
follow up this but with post study
analysis the biochemical analysis of
both tissue and also plasma but we don't
have to rely on these to make decisions
because of the real-time nature of the
behavior at endpoint so we think we'll
be able to make decisions on compounds
rapidly decide what we want to take
forward into the more traditional models
of fibrosis in this slide really shows
the the value proposition that vayan
provides to us and I think you know
importantly what this means is that we
have the ability to use less compound
when you can use less animals the
severity of the models that we use is
lower so this is pretty much in keeping
with everything that we would hope for
from the point of view of aspiring to
best practice in three hours
I think another hidden cost to running
chronic studies that we've not mentioned
now is the amount of compound that we
actually need if you imagine the amount
of compound that you would need to
support six-month diet diabetes involve
model involving daily dosing then that
is a significant compound investment and
so what we think we can do is use the
volume technology to measure behavior we
can pre dose with a single dose of
compound inhibit this behavior at
endpoint as a surrogate measure of
compounds that actually suppress the
inflammation so how do we see the future
well we hope to be looking at this
particular behavioral endpoint in a
little bit more detail to work through
more and more pharmacology to really
understand more about what the model is
telling us but what we also have to do
is work together with volume to explore
mice with humanized immune system so
this is just screenshots from from three
three papers relating to this it will be
fantastic if we could work with mice
with humanized immune system as we
believe this will give us more
confidence about clinical translation
here are just some some examples but
there are many more and I think this is
an area that we're going to see
advancing in the future so if we
consider the notion of humanized mice we
are beginning to see in the literature
examples of mice with humanized liver so
if we take this further we would like to
explore this acute inflammation model in
mice that have both humanized liver and
immune systems and we begin to see this
in the literature and I think this is a
field that will advance very rapidly and
we believe that the humanized
liver humanized immune system Mouse
could provide us with an
for translation of assets as we move
them into the into the clinic so we also
do some post study analysis as well but
in keeping with our nimble and agile
approach I want to tell you a little bit
about how we operate with another
company called transcript sick
transcript it worked through a fair
amount of our post study analysis so the
transcript or a cloud-based they have a
very flexible lab in a box system which
enables you to plug and play depending
upon essays that you want to run at any
given point in time and again this is
something that you can run real time you
can see via the cloud your experiments
being run and all the quality control
that goes with it and in actual fact
transcripts occur performing much of the
analysis of the blood samples and also
assessment of PCR from the liver you
know in our models as well so not only
do we believe we have a very efficient
way of looking at the in life component
of this particular model but we're also
adopting a much more flexible and rapid
approach to post a study analysis so if
we consider how we're actually working
on this we we will continue to do may be
conventional approaches to identify hits
we believe that the volume behavioral
model could enable us to have a high
throughput in vivo engine through which
we can rapidly profile compounds of
interest as I mentioned before in the
future we hope to be profiling our
compounds in humanized mice given the
increased relevance that we believe this
holds for us we still propose to do the
chronic studies with for example carbon
tetrachloride and we may even be able to
do these models in humanized mice
and by working through transcript tech
we get a very rapid turnaround in the
data so if we if we consider how we are
we are working so this is the drug
discovery paradigm the discovery
paradigm that I mentioned before I think
we're actually approaching this in a
different way we're actually building
out our capabilities using the vine
technology for fast-track in vivo
profiling of compounds and we're using
transcript ik to enable the bio analysis
to really accelerate our drug discovery
programs and we believe this is a very
flexible way of working it increases our
virtual footprint working through
high-tech external companies so to bring
all this together and to summarize we
actually believe that discovery has a
vital part to play in reducing attrition
in the drug discovery development
continuum we think that adoptions are
systems biology thinking and a move away
maybe from the over reductionist
approach will be key to reducing
nutrition but when we think about this
in the context of in vivo modeling it
does produce challenges in keeping with
best 3hours practice but i believe that
by being smart and adopting some lateral
thinking we can actually embrace systems
biology in our in vivo models and I
think moreover it enables us to improve
our decision-making process we can do
this in a way that isn't completely in
keeping with good three hours practice
and with that I'd like to thank you for
listening well thank you for that
informative presentation and before we
get started on the question-and-answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can
and a first question for you doctor is
this how widely do you think the mouse
automated activity tracking can be
applied beyond your example of acute
liver inflammation I think that's a
really good question and I think the
answer to that is very widely I think
there are clear applications in the
neuroscience area there are numerous
models of neurological disease and many
of these are based around rodent
activity I guess one of those would be
for example maze paradigms that would be
that would be a reasonable example and I
think clearly the automated nature of
the technology would be really
advantageous if you if you consider
learning a memory it's I think
reasonable to assume that you could
introduce some learning and memory
paradigm into the activity within the
activity cages and I think this will
give you a very hands-off and very
data-driven ability to measure the
pharmacological effects of compounds and
I think we know that there is operator
bias that significantly impacts the
ability of our models to generate you
know sound and robust data and I think
what's amazing hands off methodology
will certainly help with that one area
where I think there is clear benefits
from the digital vivarium is in
analgesia and I think the analgesia
field pretty much has been held back
largely due to the shortcomings of the
in vivo models and I think clearly the
vine technology has a direct relevance
there I think one of the important
aspects in the future is that payers not
only will we need to show significant
benefit with regards to patients disease
but I also think we will need to show
improvement in their quality of life and
I think if we then consider what quality
of my life might look like
in the preclinical models then I think
this is something that the vine
technology could be applied to because
you know we know in many human diseases
there are changes in inactivity
disruption of sleep is very common in
patients with a number of diseases and I
think maybe the vine technology may be
able to begin to model some of these if
you like more fluffy endpoints involved
in in quality of life I think you know
clearly as a direct application of the
technology we'll be in certainly lung
research the ability to measure
respiration rate directly can be applied
to models I guess of COPD and lung
fibrosis and I think this is a very
significant advantage of the vayan
technology I think more broadly as well
clearly their applicability into
side-effect testing of compounds of
interest so I think it has it has
massive potential well thank you doctor
and it looks like we have time for one
last question here can you provide a
little bit more context on how this
acute model will affect your
decision-making process regarding the
use of more chronic models of liver
fibrosis yeah I think again I think
that's a really important point and what
we are not suggesting is that you are
not going to perform the chronic models
what what this really does we believe it
enables us to have much more confidence
in those compounds that we actually take
forward into these more complex models
so so if if we were to go external with
a chronic liver of study if we were to
go through a CRO that CRO is likely to
charge maybe upwards of $120,000 for a
drug study in for example a diet model
in actual fact it could be more if you
want to include maybe harvesting and
tissue and plasma sampling and
so you know it's clear that with that
cost and maybe the time associated with
running these studies it's clear that
you need to be pretty confident in what
you actually progress into these more
chronic models it's not an area where
you want to go fishing for pharmacology
so so we believe the acute information
model enables us to make more decisions
on more compounds and then what this
actually means is you end up taking
fewer compounds into these more
expensive more time-consuming studies
and I think also if you actually also
perform these studies internally there
is still a tremendous amount of dollar
cost involving this you have sunk costs
and you also have been the invisible
costs if you like associated with
running these studies so I think this is
it's not needs or this is all about
adding to the screening funnel and it's
it's primarily about aiding better
decision-making within our drug
discovery processes and ultimately
reducing animal usage completely in
keeping with aspirations of good 3hours
practice well doctor before we wrap up
today do you have any final comments
no again I'd like to thank the
organizers for inviting me to speak I'd
like to thank everyone for listening and
feel free to email me with questions if
you would like any follow-up well thank
you doctor for your time and your
wonderful presentation and also like to
thank labrador making today's webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
April 2017 you'll receive an email from
lab roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to for that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event and until next time goodbye